mein name ist meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einer
neuen nicht lachen challenge auf meinem
kanal und heute sogar mit einer
bestrafung denn jedes mal wenn ich
lachen muss muss ich einen wodka trinken
das ist definitiv wodka netz groß
[Musik]
das ist scheiße
warum aber so ein scheiß neuer bot daher
wie nur kinder
[Musik]
gute erste clip ohne kinder
er ist auch klar was passiert einfach
auf die kamera zu berechenbar
[Musik]
man kriegt mich nur mit kinder fans
alter wo warum macht man sowas warum er
will ist einfach dumm
warum machst du so was warum wieder ein
kinderschuh
ja
steißbein
hey
[Musik]
luca menschlich lage druck werde
remakes notwendig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist einfach die wahrheit apropos und
morgens übrigens meine lieben freunde
gleich aber 18 uhr live auf youtube
kanal spiel mit einigen freunden
online.de
[Musik]
so ist das nämlich ich habe schon lange
nicht mehr gelacht warum warum das ist
doch einfach klar dass das passiert es
ist doch einfach klar dass das passiert
u
das wird gelaufen
[Musik]
wo
das ist meine schwester gewesen früher
ja aber klar war klar
warum was wollt ihr machen
pro pro ist war einfach nur klar er ist
ein graben und die fallen wahrscheinlich
rhein allerdings sei die sehr gut und er
fällt in den graben
wirklich witzig warum tust du dass du
musst einfach gleich abgerutscht genau
jetzt genau
ja wir sind 25 erwachsene schwere
menschen wir stellen uns jetzt alle
nebeneinander auf denen steht das hält
er bestimmt aus
weniger essen immer so leute die zum
ersten motorrad sitzen und die geben
immer instant vollgas jetzt auch nicht
wo ich kenne es einfach auch bei
techniken hey ich weiß nicht aber das
miteinander vergleichen kann aber wenn
ich da noch nie fahrrad gefahren bin
dann gehe ich da auch nicht aus farben
gibt direkt vollgas
es regnet und die filmmusik einfach ich
bin eigentlich recht gut unterwegs heute
die sind einfach genau gleich aus
alter ist es hier der trailer zu la
bohème jetzt damals in der schule mal
die hose gerissen weil ich dachte das
wäre cool mal die hosen voll tief trägt
und bin ich gelaufen über den schulhof
wenn sie sagt sie steht auf männer mit
bart
nein nein das bin einfach ich das
auch traurig spaß machen so der ist
nicht gut
also da ach so
[Musik]
und jedes mal so die ich je gemacht habe
jesus jesus ist dass wir von dieser
rapper crew jesus auch stark
wenn man alleine spielen muss
[Musik]
sehr gut
im public lobbys zusammengefasst hat ein
ihm auf twitter bist die fünfte
[Musik]
everyone als immer so immer so ich weiß
nicht warum das so ist aber irgendwie
ist rot immer suspicious im herzen fällt
auch immer so wenn ich mit sandra im
podcast folge aufnehme sander setz dich
hin und ich sage dann ey du musst du
noch irgendwie ein bierchen holen oder
du musst noch die mutter monika holen
für die fragerunde oder irgendwie so
heute abend kommt übrigens der neue
podcast verordnen um nur aber jedes mal
wenn sandra einmal sind sagt sie einfach
nähe das halt ohne machen wie ich stehe
jetzt nicht noch mal auf einmal weil sie
zu faul ist dann aufzustehen
es war doch so klar
ich glaube in jeder nicht nach
einschätzung von mir bisher mindestens
ein clip drin wo leute in den pool
springen wollten aber vorher
ausgerutscht sind
das sind jungs lachen 900 november war
das im plan sind der ballade ja was er
wollte einfach die leute mit einer
banane abwerfen
ach der ist für dich
[Musik]
wow
an der stelle ich das heute wieder
beende lieben freunde wenn euch diese
trainer tun lacht challenge mit mir
gefallen hat dann lasst einen daumen
hoch und video.de abonniert haben einen
kanal und wenn ich irgendwann kommen